thousand go and read my name is Pierre
pack
welcome to Erie I really don't know much
about is the guy again and came out
today on the Soraa it's free and it
looks really good to be a free game okay
I think I may look it look good for a
while oh okay I came from that all right
let's look all right actually all right
notices gain entry to plant grounds you
spray paint to mark casualty a slash
danger and I have an inventory
I like the font that they use ah
it's actually kind of beautiful uh
design all right what are we getting
what is it a spray can alright plan
numero or not finita what do I have had
what did I asked eart it's not a skirt
maybe it's a kilt could be a kills well
well I can spray zombies in the faces I
don't even know it
hold see all right I'm holding see
pretty sure anyone who plays indie games
know how to crawl just never mind
all right you move a little too fast for
my flavor all right what do we got here
like ah [ __ ] you what was that but
what's that don't tell me don't kill me
I'm innocent I'm innocent I tell you
fine let me get a chance to read it son
of a [ __ ] everywhere now which way do
we go papa gang outside work work work
Berber well I can jump like run like a
boss I've been here ha ha
I can draw whatever I want oh that's
just that much that looks like a
ah here was hey beautiful hey das all
right
I'm enjoying this kind a lot actually
what the hell is this oh I better not
walk there or blood
door lock magnetically [ __ ] bow I'm
knocking you to death
holy [ __ ] Rose this game all right yeah
why the hell was that oh what's that
thing what shut up all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna spray my graffiti pooper hell
yeah I'm better I love this feature best
idea ever
I can draw dicks whenever I want oh all
right
this game it's awesome it's free I think
this is probably the most I have only
played to four minutes but this is
probably the best game that's free that
I played in a long while at least it
looks really well-made all right let's
keep going breasts hi
no no we do not go there is there
something with the light like if there's
others light here alright I'm coming
I got a better mark the brofist to know
where we are that's not a brofist god
damnit that's immature pair they're
immature what
sorry mature alright let's mark with a
brofist
brofist means with bin here brofist
penis okay okay uh-huh all right so I'm
gonna draw like this to understand that
I walk this way
hello water charlie good weather here
today what is this
set a person as a dog or what is that
alrighty then so rats hate rats odds
even worse Sal's gonna draw stuff a
little luck a lot it's a cat
kitty cat poor kitty cat I picked up a
cat prisoners time okay Wow
why is there like a baby crying baby
crying it's usually never good news I
would have gotten here
stashed lab key in lobsters so okay shut
up my fish all right so we need to go
through upstairs ow
uh-huh keep going I suppose Bok Bok Bok
Bok Bok Bok Bok Bok
[ __ ] butterflies I mean uh yeah
whatever
all right I've been here yes I have
beautiful
all right now when eaten me up in here
come on stop right what is that what is
that don't kill me
is this Lobby key a lobby seems nicer
than this [ __ ] place that sounds
really real not a cat huh what is up
with the dead cats not cool
why would he kill cats like that all
right
uh no no no no no no hello I'm only PETA
pie I don't mean you no harm
what's going on here oh hell no oh hell
no okay what does it say date 11 August
1966 what okay what about this
first September our efforts to introduce
forest mutation Oh and ever Sesker been
met with alarm in really subject I can't
it just stops going away what I have to
do whole D I'm holding a subdivide
fortune in the interest of time we
introduced a formula six currently it
was running its ball so I guess you can
pause and read that I can't do that
apparently master key required or Master
Chief
all right let's get the mastered key
haha okay I get it
that's our escape magically somehow
alright we've been here went a little
triple balls on that one little smiley
face Burt beautiful give him arms
actually they're not arms their dicks
thought about that alright let's good
guy
Ren what uh well this room needs paint
what happened okay I click that oh [ __ ]
that what Ron Ron Ron Ron what is that
well I don't like this I got goose bumps
man or women is it coming for me scared
of women uh period that's why every time
I go oh baby baby why can't we do what I
write out don't kill me ah how are you
doing dancing over my body despite me I
hate when that happens
oh geez what stop dancing Jesus Christ I
get the point
pissed if he does that again alright
then let me respawn thankfully alright
so I know the tactic I just I just need
to go out of thing this scares the [ __ ]
out of me
even when you run it's like freakish
[ __ ] the master key I already have it
right
it's [ __ ] blood everywhere man I
really are
oh [ __ ] it freaks out automated [ __ ]
freaks out out of it all right all right
all right Plan B blender and I run where
I put wet right well what is this place
uh-oh the [ __ ] am i [ __ ] hand
frontflips okay oh you just [ __ ]
teasing me when they are aren't you
alright generator be gentle with me and
my poor little heart please please be
gentle okay they're all denied probably
nice at all at all at all if it's done
at all at all of it
haha [ __ ]
I'm so lost I'm so lost in the corridor
why does he want to kill me so much why
did I have oh no what
what in hell they're all offline it's
gonna be here in a second yeah all right
that's enough for me for today I can
ferry the fish enjoy um I'm totally
impressed by this game I think I would
pay for this at least I mean it's
awesome I love the style I love it it's
really cool I'm gonna leave a download
link if you wanna check it out and like
a peerage enjoyed the sky ride today I'm
sorry 2k much farther I'll try Nate next
episode lobby breath nice voicecrack
there